the autopilot is a constructive belief
or behavior so let's say simple example
if someone says socially I find it
difficult to get on with people and I
say let's have a look at how you
introduce yourself and let's say they're
com in and they something very simple is
as an example uh and they say hello and
the person says hello and then there's
this pause and they said then I feel
really awkward and I just don't know
what to do yeah so what you've got is
you've actually got a program which is
to pause so that's a gremling because
it's not helpful you're being
uncomfortable it's leading to an
emotional chimp reaction so we say right
what could we program the computer to do
so quite simple is social skills we
would just say ask them oh where have
you come from today and that breaks the
eyes so you're programming automatic
speech and then this art feels a lot
better now because I know what I'm
doing